-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from shows like
"The Path" and "Hannibal."
He stars in the 21st season
of "Law & Order,"
which airs Thursday nights
right here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Find out
what they were talking about.
-Tried. She made herself
part of the defense team,
filed an appearance
at the arraignment.
-Okay.
So let's work with what we have.
You've tried cases
without motive before.
-I have,
but not first-degree murder
and not when the defendant
was a global icon.
-Just tell the jury
what you have
and what you don't have.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Hugh Dancy, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome.
-Thank you.
-I was telling you backstage,
I am --
I'm so happy to have
this franchise back.
It's so nice
to see Sam Waterston.
To be in a room with him
must be just a joy.
-It's incredible.
It was amazing
being in that room
that you just saw with him
when he walked back into it
after 11 years, I'm gonna say?
-Yeah.
-Which I can only assume
that his mind was melting.
But you just saw Sam's face.
You know, impassive, kind of...
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, incredible.
-And this is --
You know, the last time
you were, I guess,
probably on an NBC show,
you were FBI profiler
Will Graham on "Hannibal."
And a fantastic show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And maybe you would think --
You're currently playing
an A.D.A.,
obviously dealing
with New York crime.
And yet maybe easier than what
Will Graham was dealing with.
-Nobody is trying to eat me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That should be the tagline.
-That must be a nice departure.
-Yes, it is.
-"If you enjoy Hugh Dancy
and don't want
to see him get eaten,
this is the show for you,
the new 'Law & Order.'"
-But I'm not sure that people
did want to see that.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
But it feels like
a net positive.
-Yes, it does feel
like a net positive.
And you get to film
in New York City.
-Yes.
-And you have obviously
done theater in New York City.
-Mm-hmm.
And again, I think one of the
joys of watching "Law & Order,"
especially over 21 seasons,
is you saw so many
incredible stage actors populate
that cast over the years.
-Literally every stage actor.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I've --
Again, Sam says this.
He feels that Dick Wolf
should get a Tony
for his services to the theater.
You know?
Everybody I've worked with
has been doing --
Except for me, so now I feel --
-So, this is a big deal
for you to finally --
to finally make it
onto a "Law & Order."
-Yeah. As somebody
who's been lucky enough
to work in the theater but also
somebody who lives here...
-Yeah.
-...it feels a little
validating, for sure.
-And your wife, Claire Danes,
has been on "Law & Order."
-I think I'm right in saying
it was her first job.
-It was her first job?
-Yeah. She played a murderer.
-Did she really?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-Good for her.
That's a really good first job.
-Yes! It is.
-I feel like the best they would
ever give me on "Law & Order"
is the jogger who sees a body.
[ Laughter ]
-You could be on the jury.
-I wouldn't --
I'd want to be the jogger.
I want to be the jogger
who's talking to another jogger
about some real, you know, B.S.,
and then, all of a sudden,
it's like, "Oh, my God!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Hard cut,
then I'm talking to someone.
I'm like,
"Yeah, I was just jogging."
-In the background,
talking to you.
-Now I'm in the background,
overacting.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I mean, again, somebody
has to do that job, you know?
-Somebody has to do that job.
Well, you know Dick Wolf now.
Put in a word for me.
-Done.
-Thank you.
I would imagine it's also
really cool to shoot on --
You know, the New York City
streets are your set.
-Yeah.
I mean, the advantage --
I play, as you say, the A.D.A.,
so I'm prosecuting.
I'm in, like, the second half
of the show, mostly.
Lawyers, it turns out,
are not the ones
that go out into Central Park
at midnight.
-That's true.
-Which is great for me.
-Yeah.
-It's --
That's Anthony Anderson
and Jeffrey Donovan.
They're out there
doing that good stuff,
and I'm mostly in the studio.
But it's great --
Just again, the New York --
Just before I came here,
I was in an Italian butcher's,
and a woman turned to me
and said,
"You're doing great on 'L&O.'"
[ Laughter ]
And I thought she said, "You
were great on the 'Ellen' show."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I thought to myself --
This is like an hour ago,
and I thought, "I was great
on the 'Ellen' show,
but it was in 2003."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So that's a long memory
she's got.
-I wish you'd overreacted and
said, "I've waited so long..."
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
-"...for someone
to give me that feedback."
-"Thank you, madam!"
[ Laughs ]
-You're also in the new
"Downton Abbey" film.
That, I guess, is a little bit
more like your roots,
a little bit more costume drama,
which you did
back in the early days.
Was it nice to get back in those
sort of British period pieces?
-It was.
It was --
That kind of dropped out of
the sky for me, post-pandemic.
So there was a kind of feeling
of massive relief, honestly,
that I was working,
but a strange feeling
that I had been
transported back 20 years
in time in my own career.
-Yeah.
-But then, you know, to find
myself in that stately home,
surrounded by all those icons,
you know, sipping tea
and kind of gossiping in between
takes, was amazing.
-Your boys are 9 and 3.
Do they engage
with your work at all?
Is there anything of yours
that they care about?
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
I mean,
that's a tough question, Seth.
-It's a tough age.
-Yes, yeah, it is.
And the youngest one probably
doesn't really know enough
to care, and the oldest one --
Well, actually, the oldest one,
I took him -- I went to --
They screened today.
The people who made it
screened "Downton Abbey"
for me this morning.
So before the Italian butchers,
that's where I was.
And I took him with me --
boldly, some would say --
because I didn't know
what his response would be.
But he came to love it.
-Oh, that's really sweet.
-Yeah.
-That's all you can ask for.
-He turned to me
in the middle of the screening
and he said, "This is good."
[ Laughter ]
"You're good."
"You're an actor."
[ Laughter ]
The last bit
I'm still mulling over.
-Yeah.
-'Cause it's accurate.
-But it's also quite neutral.
-The thing that just
gave me goose bumps is,
I feel like
that would be the dream
I would want my father
to turn to me and say.
And I'm like, "Wait.
Does that mean you get
a new father
that's just a young one?"
-It was so validating.
-Yeah.
-And then, at the end, I said --
and this is gonna seem desperate
because it probably was,
but I said,
"So, what was
your favorite bit?"
And he said --
Honestly, he said,
"The bit when they hired you."
[ Laughter ]
Which, again,
could have been a plot point
in the movie when you see it.
But it was ambiguous.
[ Laughter ]
"Me, too!"
-"We just need you to work, Dad.
We just need you
to keep working."
Hey, congratulations again
on the show.
It's so nice to see you.
That's Hugh Dancy, everybody.
"Law & Order"
airs Thursdays at 8:00 p.m.,
here on NBC.
And "Downton Abbey: A New Era"
will be in theaters on May 20th.